I want to get just a little bit into SNL
that was that was a harder audition
right
um yeah it's probably the hardest
audition I've ever done how many times
you go in I had to do the test three
times in front of Lauren yeah three
times in front of Lauren yes and how
long does this take five minutes the
actual audition itself yeah you don't
want to go too far past between five and
seven minutes I think is probably the
ideal once you're over 10 minutes you
know unless you're something super
special it's kind of like you didn't get
it
um and what'd you do a lot of different
things when he first saw me and he had
come to the Groundlings to see Naseem
um because I think Tina Fey recommended
her to Lauren so he came to the Sunday
company we were performing there he came
to a show he flew four of us out I did
um I forget because of the three ones
but I I always did at least two or three
original pieces characters either like
characters from sketches I did at
Groundlings or like dumb silly bits that
I'd come up with and then I always tried
to do more Impressions just to show
variety and show relevancy what
Impressions did you did you do that the
third time the third time God the third
time was interesting I I think like I
threw Brad in there I maybe did Michael
Sarah uh Michael Sarah quickly do a
Sarah if oh this is so great just just a
bunch of guys sort of sort of hanging
out and just just podding it up
talk about about fan ship and and sort
of what what inspires you I guess at the
end of the day that's the most important
part right that's great okay because you
did Sarah
um at one point I did
Dr Claw from Inspector Gadget having
phone sex with Paul Giamatti oh my God
what is that just like okay ah I guess I
put my hand on your thigh yes
I think I did Seth Rogen at one point I
certainly did Jack Black at one point uh
I did Tom Hanks which is like well
you've got a
gotta be it's not great but you
definitely